what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at Sundance 2024 I'm so
happy to be doing this interview with
the team behind it's what's inside I'm
obsessed with your movie I haven't
stopped thinking about it
congratulations thank you thank you so
before we get into our conversation I
have to give a very special shout out to
the fine folks at filo for sponsoring
our Sundance Studio this year big thanks
to them and also they are a very
impressive company that is breaking
barriers by putting the power to
Greenlight movies in the hands of fans
and creators if you want to learn more
about filo and their Community check out
their website
film. okay I'm giving you these duties
because I'm afraid to spoil anything
just in case our viewers do not know
what it's inside is just yet can it's
what's inside yet can you give them a
brief description of the film yes it's
what's inside is about a a pre-wedding
party between eight old College friends
where one is strange Trend shows up
played by this gentleman right here uh
and he brings a suitcase and the
suitcase unlocks what we're calling an
existential nightmare uh the movie
itself is an examination of the uh male
gaze the commodification of
relationships and the sort of how the
over sexualization of uh our media
affects uh both sides of a relationship
a plus job without going too far I'm
Mighty impressed so this is your first
feature and that is a very very big deal
two questions about that can you tell us
one thing you did that was helpful and
helped make this movie a reality but
then also can you pinpoint a roadblock
that you came across by this being your
first film and tell us how you overcame
it oh sure I mean roadblocks I think
just kind of getting it m made funded
like I I I wrote it back in
2016 and um there were uh it just had a
series of fits and starts really uh and
just kind of getting someone to sort of
believe in it and then getting it financ
uh it would really it was just uh one of
our producers Kate gave it to another
producer Raul who gave it to Coleman
Domingo gave no other producer and
that's essentially how how Bill
Rosenfeld uh which is which is
ultimately how it got made but it was
just really like perseverance and just
kind of not giving up I guess um but the
there were really many times when I
really just didn't think it it was going
to happen definitely didn't think we'd
be here um so sorry and I forgot your
first question oh some like something
good you did something that you did that
helped make the movie a reality and
maybe even something that you would
recommend to another first-time feature
filmmaker who wants to make their first
film oh yeah I mean I think it's just uh
just don't give up really I mean um yeah
just uh don't give up keep you know you
go through a lot or I want I feel like
most filmakers go through a lot of
rejection in trying to get that first
thing made um maybe people will tell you
that they like your script but they
don't want to make it in this case I I
was told that it was too confusing it
was very confusing uh so yeah you just
have to just just kind of persevere and
stick through I guess I don't know if
you'll be able to answer this next
question while avoiding spoilers you
brought up you started working on this
in 2016 what would you say is the
biggest difference between draft one of
this screenplay and the finished film oh
that's a good qu um yeah uh if you need
to pass I understand
um
I guess I'll say the biggest difference
is the nature of David's character
that's sorry that's so vague take that
yeah I'll take that tease I look forward
to this getting a distributor at this
festival and following you like
everywhere you go so we'll have an
opportunity to have a spoiler
conversation eventually great I look
forward to it it is make Greg blush time
so again this is his first feature film
I have very high hopes he's going to go
on to direct many more can each of you
tell me something about him as an
actor's director and leader that you
appreciated and you're excited for more
actors to experience in the
future
um sorry were you about to say something
no um we had a week of rehearsal before
we started shooting and that's super
rare um and the fact that he factored
that in was really really special and
really helpful for what happens in this
movie and um yeah and also just like
your VIs
was so clear and I think just showing up
we all immediately kind of trusted this
seeing the set seeing like everything
come to light like you knew exactly what
you were doing and I feel like that was
really really exciting to work with a
director like that he's also so
supportive in letting us really take
risks and big chances even things that
don't make it into the film sometimes he
would let us go way further and
improvise and and take a lot of chances
just so we could kind of build this team
and and um just an incredibly supportive
good person that made us all I think
feel really safe when we're working with
him I think also he's um he really lives
the scene with you like you'll you
you'll turn around and you you finish a
scene and he's like smiling and beaming
and he's excited for the for the next
moment he's like we maybe we could try
this or we could try that and as an
actor you never feel like you're
disappointing him you always feel like
there's more so you're craving more from
yourself to to go deep deeper and to to
explore and um I don't know we walked to
every day we I don't know we all you
know fell in love with each other but it
it was through your it all stop starts
from the top so yeah he's having so much
fun when he's directing I mean like he's
his first audience so he's so psyched
about everything we're doing like it
feels like we're performing for him the
whole time does he have a monitor dance
like something he does behind the
monitor that signals to you he's loving
to take uh I do I do like a high pitch
Yelp uh Giggles often like a woo yeah
yes yes you get this craz look in your
eye and you're just like yeah guys
that's what I love about Greg he's just
so enthusiastic and so passionate and it
just it just brings such a good energy
to the set we're all just so happy to be
there because he's so happy you know
it's magical it's fun thank you it being
such an ensemble piece too like there's
opportunities where maybe you could like
get lost in an ensemble but Greg was
always really attentive to everyone like
each of us I feel like had one-on ones
that were so crucial to developing our
characters and knowing where we were
what we were doing long conversations
about that I mean early on I had I
didn't really know how to make a sense
of the script because there was so so
much going on and uh you know sitting
down with you I was like oh this guy
really knows what he's doing and that
just it it felt that way throughout the
whole shoot like you always you were the
North Star where like there there was
always a clear sense of we were going in
the right direction cuz you knew knew
even if we were getting a little uh
delirious at 4 in the morning I think
you oh go ahead no no no you're so
polite um I think one thing you get your
best work or you do your best work when
you're comfortable and you feel safe and
just as you know to piggyback off of um
what everybody's saying is I I I the
other thing I think that Greg is has
done brilliantly was you know when we
were in the rehearsal process I think a
brilliant director also has Trust
in their actors and and takes a step
back and observes and he was he felt
confident enough in our abilities and we
all had to trust each other in this
process without giving anything away and
he gave us Direction he observed and he
it's almost like uh I would describe it
as like a scientist watching something
kind of like unfold and knowing like you
created something and he allows it to to
grow or I don't I'm not a scientist but
you know he um a mad Greg is um in the
art and so I thought that that was um it
allowed us to flourish and create these
grounded realistic characters and to
create these bonds you know um he great
he created a great moment for James and
I to to um create this relationship and
you know that's kind of a thread
throughout the story so um and it was
just it was so empowering to work with a
director like Greg and to work with you
know the people that he chose to be on
this film I mean his great
taste I also just thought it was really
um incredible and impressive the way
that like there would be a million
things going on you'd be you'd be
figuring something out with this with
this big crazy house we in and and and
setting up some insane shot that takes
you all across the entire property and
all the while through all that um you'd
still have the time to stop and talk to
us about a moment or you know there
would be like the the 3:00 a.m. phone
call of like let's talk about this thing
or you know or stepping into your office
and there's Hawaiian music playing and
you know and sending us like oh listen
to this song you know I just think it
was like the the fact that you were
really able to um give everyone the
attention that they needed uh all the
while addressing the million of other
things going on I think is a a a a
testament to to
your capabilities as a as a director how
you feel guys oh you guys made me blush
said it would happen it happened success
I'm glad you were all very good at
passing the mics around cuz I have
another big group question obviously we
don't want to spoil anything but I do
want to take a moment to tease your
characters a little bit can each of you
tell me your character's greatest
strength at the beginning of the film
but then I also want to know their
greatest weakness the thing that could
do them in in this wild situation that
unfolds I'm like I'm G to keep it super
vague but Brook's greatest I'm like
bursting at the seams right now like
just so eager to shout to the world
about all the cuz like you keep saying
like people found it confusing I feel
like it's just so appropriately
disorienting for the first half of the
movie and then you start using these
visual techniques that everything comes
together like so seamlessly and of
course through your performances as well
so it's like it's important that it had
that quality but you get the the balance
there yeah we we we just try to juggle
what we called like good confusion
versus bad confusion uh good confusion
is what I'd refer to like I'm a huge
David Lynch guy like you know his stuff
is confusing in the best way for me uh
and then there's back confusion where
you're just like man I don't know what's
like I'm like like I've I've I've
disconnected from this experience so
hopefully it's not it's on the bad side
but anyway rain now confusion yes uh I
think Brooke her greatest strength is
that she has a lot of
energy yes uh the weakness is definitely
insecurity she just really wants to be
loved and she'll will do the wrong
things for it I
think good answer uh I think Shelby's
strength uh comes through evolution of
her ability to observe
situations um and I think um she grows
from a point of weakness where uh she uh
settles for less than she
deserves
I think forbes's greatest strength is uh
the love that he carries for all of his
friends and I think that you know he
just he'll he'll do anything to to to to
bring them back into his life and and I
think uh and I think his downfall is as
huis
um that's good huis hubus yeah I don't
know no that was great you guys are
doing
great um I would say uh Ruben's greatest
strength is to be the sun in a room
where he can brighten everyone's day he
can make you feel like oh thank you not
not how to describe myself but um um but
I would say his greatest weakness is
also that he feels potentially that his
personality is built off the basis of
how his mother was and the pressure of
living underneath his um the huge
personality of his
mother great man you guys you guys good
glad no one asked me this
question uh I feel like Dennis's
strength is probably his ego he's uh
he's really um built a very strong
personality to protect himself from uh
the world and uh his privilege and uh
his insecurity is probably like that
soft jelly center of who he really is
that um he doesn't he doesn't want
anyone else to see his tough guy but not
really um I think Maya's greatest
strength is um the acceptance of others
she accepts everyone she's super um warm
um and I
think her weakness is I think she
doesn't quite know who she
is um I think she's like on a a journey
um trying to figure it out and um
yeah oh man I don't know I mean what's
his greatest strength I I don't know if
he has necessarily that many Cyrus has
many strengths his ability to stress out
a sentence yeah yeah I mean I yeah I I I
mean I think Cyrus's greatest strength
is that he's like he's
always he's trying to make it work with
his relationship with Shelby uh but in
doing so he's extremely dishonest and is
never really willing to say what he
means and so that's his greatest
weakness is that he's always hedging and
he can never commit to what he wants so
he can never really commit to the
relationship he's in and so he's always
kind of half in half out throughout the
whole movie and and he gets his come up
for it I'll end with another group
question that doesn't have to stress you
out in terms of spoilers but I will say
those were good descriptions in
hopefully everyone out there gets a
sense of like I know the pieces on the
game board and how they could be
shuffled around through all of this so
Greg a lot of your director statement
was all about the idea of you know the
appeal of being able to escape reality
through Sci-Fi movies and getting the
opportunity to experience the impossible
through them so for each of you can you
name like a Sci-Fi or any genre movie
that you would want to step into and
experience the impossible that that
movie
presents
whoa how do you choose one I think about
this a lot I learned nothing from
Jurassic Park I want to walk into that
movie and make a
dinosaur I mean I feel like my go-to
answer is Blade Runner um yeah that's
mine I mean ET would be cool cuz then I
have like a little alien friend you know
and I that would be really nice I I
really like uh the
arrival so big backing off of like of
aliens well like I just think it's oh
arrival sorry rival uh cuz I like the
whole aspect of you know the aliens
actually being there to bring everyone
together um even though it's terrifying
but it was like my first sci-fi movie I
actually really connected with because
there was that emotional
component Spirited
Away yeah that be be so cool that'd be
so cool I would love to just coming I
love that answer be a Chito like that'd
be great
yeah de Deon
go no cuz all I've got is Attack the
Block in my head right now because I'm
just like oh it's just such a cool world
and I just love that film so I was like
this is crazy but I don't think I would
want to be on that world so I'm like
yeah as deadly as that scenario is I
don't care that movie rocks I definitely
want to like see how I would do against
those aliens y y I I don't know I feel
like most sci-fi that I can think of
right now is like it highlights all the
kind of worst parts of humanity and and
like and how it's you know how we're
sort of doomed I not to get gloomy you
know but but um I don't know maybe like
like Eternal Sunshine or something that
feels like that could be a helpful thing
uh you know at at at a couple moments in
uh in in my life I'd be like yeah it'd
be great to just put all that in a bag
and get rid of that
um I'm with David I can only think of D
I love movies about dystopian societies
like I love that stuff but I don't think
I necessarily want to uh live there so I
guess like any movie where like dogs
talk also a very good
answer yeah I'm a big Blade Runner fan
too I think that would be he'll yeah
I'll go BL 2049 so we don't have the
same
answer fair enough fair enough all
excellent selections and seriously it's
what's inside phenomenal film I am
obsessing over it I can't wait to watch
it over and over and analyze every
single detail of your performances and
the world you build overall I'm rooting
for you all the best and thanks for
being thanks for us big thanks to
everybody out there watching thanks to
our sponsor filo and stay tuned for more
from Sundance